هو لا شك هناك هذا المشروع امتد ايضا
عبرات السنين الى ان يعني تاطر ايضا في
اطار الافاده العامه في جميع المناطق يعني
كثير من المناطق الجزيره العربيه عندما
يتحدث عن اي مجال هم يقفون على ان امر
الامني الذي لا يستطيعون ان يتحركوا من
منطقه الى منطقه اخرى اللي تحققت بفضل
الله عز وجل بوقوف ايضا هذه الدوله وضبطت
ايضا الاجراءات الامنيه فاصبح ايضا هناك
القضاه وهناك اقامه الاحكام العادله وهناك
ايضا العسكريين وهناك ايضا التكوينات ايضا
الدوله وهناك ايضا تكوين الجيش الدوله
الان واختيارهم وكفاءتهم
فلذلك اصبح الان ولهذا يقول المؤرخ لدينا
مؤرخ ابن بشر يقول اذا ضاعت ناقه او اذا
ضاعت شاه في اقصى الجزيره العربيه في
جنوبها الى شمالها لا يستطيع انسان ان
ياخذها بسبب الامن الذي استقر في هذه
الارجاع في الحقيقه هي شيء ضخم جدا لم
يتحقق لهذه الجزيره هذا الاستقرار الامني
تسلط الضوء عليه بشكل كافي اللي هو كيف تم
انشاء جهاز اداري داخلي على مستوى عالي من
الكفاءه والاداره ايضا وهذه الحقيقه يعني
يتبع الان كثير من الباحثين وايضا كثير من
المهتمين لا بد ان يبرز هذا الجانب الامني
في تكوين الدوله ربما ان يقام ايضا يوم
خاص مؤتمرات خاصه ليوم للامن لاي يستشعروا
هذه الاجيال الجديده يعني تصور اخي الكريم
استاذنا ان الانسان ينتقل من شمال جزيره
العربيه الان وضعنا الحالي من 2005 كيلو
الى نجران لا يستطيع ان يدب في نفسه الخوف
في تلك المرحله السابقه قبل قيام الدوله
السعوديه لا يستطيع الانسان ان يعبر كيلو
واحد من منطقه الى منطقه نعم بسبب الخوف
ولهذا لابد ان يستشعر هؤلاء الجيل الجديد
باهميه هذا الامن واننا نقول هذا الكلام
جزافا بل تكلم عنه الغربيون وتكلم عنه
الكثير الحقيقه
امر البلاد المجاور في النهايه اشقاء يعني
نشوف الوضع في سوريا تشوف الوضع في اليمن
تشوف الوضع في غيرها من البلدان يعني اشبه
بما تحدثت عنه لا احد يستطيع انتقل من
مكان لمكان نقاط سيطره ولا تدري هذا تبع
مين ولهذا حتى المؤرخين الاجانب او حتى
الذين كتبوا ضد تاريخ هذه الدوله عندما
يشيرون يقول ومن محاسن هؤلاء
السعوديون انهم استطاعوا ضبط الامن في
الجزيره حتى من الاعداء مثلا عثمان بن سند
من اشهر الاعداء الذين كتبوا خارج الدوله
ويقول وين المحاسبني الضخمه انهم امنوا
هذه البلاد فيستطيع الانسان ان ينتقل من
مكان الى اخر لا يخاف وهذا الحقيقه ميزه
ضخمه يجب ان يعبر عنها الحقيقه الان يعبر
ايضا عنها في الايام وغير ذلك لان هذه
الامر مهم جدا